foreign
welcome back to a highly important
episode of careful boys today we out
with us Mr Jesus
careful boys careful you got to be
careful he's there
so we were getting questions uh this one
person asked and I thought it'd be good
to to answer just in general he was
having trouble quitting smoking and he
was like Hey I know I know maybe some of
you guys might have smoked in the past
how what can I do to like uh quit what
did you do get Vapes bro no I'm kidding
I'm really kidding
I started smoking when I was 12 or 13.
as experimental who got you into it what
a cool ass I think like when you're a
kid that's kind of bad you know you
start well I think fifth grade might
have been the first time we just stole
someone's dad's pack of cigarettes and
then we're just like we
and then we're like trying it right so
how old is that like fifth grade is that
eleventh fifth grade it's like 10 11
yeah something like that and then I was
like that's gross and then in middle
school
I remember in Middle School we're like
skating we're at the skate park and a
bunch of guys are smoking cigarettes and
then my friend's like can I have one and
then they're like sure and then they
give them one and he goes
and I was like oh [__] and then we're
like smoking right and then the guy came
back he goes you're not even inhaling it
and then we're just like going like
they're like no no he goes what you see
other people yeah when you take it when
you take a hit you always breathe after
and then so we're like
[Laughter]
and then we're just like [__] now you
want to watch kid
they were dying they were just [__]
laughing at us but then we get the the
[__] head thing over just like yeah
oh but it tastes so gross you know and
then you have to really try to smoke
yeah it was kind of gross [__] try it
was just cool but it was just like gross
but I I kind of only got into it when I
was like on ecstasy yeah like Menthol
manthals are good you just chain smoke
the [__] out of it but then like once
you're off it I'm like I don't I don't
want cigarettes at all no one's like
like [__] just sexually like
tantalizing your lungs on the inside out
you know like someone's just like just
caressing your ends I like all that the
way you do it like does it at all help
the guy quit smoking he just goes on to
ecstasy that sounds like tequila but
well my thing was like when I used to
smoke when I started as a comic because
all the comics would do it and then Dave
Chappelle will do it so I'm like oh
[__] thing so it's just like a cool
thing it'll just be all like but then I
just didn't like the smell and taste of
it and then I was just like yeah [__]
this I'm done and I was I just
it is a weird social thing because in
the military like a lot of people have
like you don't really have breaks but
there's smoke breaks right smoking dip
breaks so when the smoke breaks
everyone's like okay cool one like goes
to the corner everyone's smoking and
then I want to chill with you so I just
go
yeah I'm not smoking but I do feel weird
I do feel weird like
but that's the thing about smoking too
right I think a big part of it is a lot
of people that smoke they do it when
they're stressed or like when they're
trying to like they attach it to
something like really like oh I'm trying
to chill or relax or I need a break and
then they start smoking it becomes a
habit over time and then it becomes
attached to this thing of like oh I
associate this with like me chilling or
taking a load up when you were starting
smoking I think it was the hardest thing
to quit because I've done a lot of
different drugs and then like I was
never addicted to any drugs really I was
just able to quit but then smoking I
just couldn't [__] quit because did
you relate it to like something like
that that makes you relax it's like
I don't know if it made me relax I just
knew that like even when I was the
closest I got to quitting was one a day
because I still had to smoke one because
it would be on my mind all day and then
after I smoked when I was like okay cool
I could go to sleep now how did you like
break it well there was one time when I
was
what was I like 24 23 that I quit for
one year and then like I got back on I
forgot how I got back on and then I
tried to quit on and off so I would like
stop for like a month or whatever but
the final quit was 2019. and I think I
talked about it before too here but like
I was just like
um just got out of a relationship and I
was like you know what
I think the only way I'm gonna quit is
if I create like a rehab for myself
where I'm not in the same routine I'm
not in the same element I'm not around
cigarettes and I'm doing something
physical because I know that um the more
like I was physically exhausted I didn't
want to smoke it was like when you
started working out like crazy yeah
that's when I was working out like twice
or doing Spartan run and this or like
just trying to do things stay active yes
yeah because then when I'm active like
let's say I do like an eight mile run I
don't want to smoke cigarettes I know
people who still work out and smoke but
for me the next day I feel like [__]
when I'm trying to do a pull-up that
[__] is Gangster though they got
cigarettes yeah like there's people that
are like that what gym are you guys
going to [__] Venice Beach man
I had a friend who would like after we
go work out he he would just pop a
cigarette after we'd lift weights and
I'm like that feels so gross to me oh we
would do Spartan races and we knew
someone she would um she would smoke
cigarettes during the race or like yeah
that's cool [__] hardcore [__] imagine
they take a picture of you like climbing
the bar and yeah
first yeah yeah
is that like a uh dude raise the [__]
uh racist flag if it's getting racy but
do Asians like really love smoking or
something yeah
my whole family smoked dude like all my
especially like Asia [__] crazy
everybody said yeah I worked at a Korean
uh barbecue place and um the whole place
Buena Park and when I'm parking and then
[__] we would have like breaks like
through the middle of the day we would
just stop for two hours you worked on a
k BBQ spot I'm going apart yeah dude
he's probably been there
um it used to be it used to be right
there at Knox Berry Farm it was back in
the day it should be by Knoxville it's
still there is it yeah the Korean
barbecue spot by Knott's Berry Farm is
still there I'll go there pretty
regularly with my mom
a little ice cream thing right in the
middle yes yes they used to work there
they used to work there I don't know
what they were saying but when I walked
in it would go like you guys both don't
know the name
I know I could show you the picture but
I don't know but anyway but you don't
know the name yeah hey you guys hiring
and [__] and I wanted to be a sushi
Guyana or like
yeah
[Laughter]
they just had a bunch of little grills
in them what the [__] is this it just
brings a girl out like in my head dude
in my head I was like and that's the
thing you just use so much [__] trace
for stupid [__] like
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
what worked for me was basically I was a
part of this karate club that would do
karate boot camps and so they would rent
out like a dorm or whatever out of a
university and then so for about a week
straight you go to this spot so I can't
bring cigarettes there because what I'm
gonna do like [__] hiya with a
cigarette in my mouth like that's a
[__] cool though sick ass sound bite
but then they they they physically
exhaust you to the point where like you
don't want to do [__] but just sleep
like if you every if you have three
hours you try to sleep because they're
gonna wake your ass up in the middle of
the night and then like don't don't do
surprise drills right so you [__] you
finish out or you just finish a workout
or an attacker in your room yeah and
then and then it's like midnight and
you're like all right [__] time to go to
sleep so you [__] knock out and then
like you hear Thor yeah basically they
[__] bang on your door and like [__]
up at three in the morning wake up wake
up wake up and oh [__] okay it's three
in the morning [__] and then you get up
you put your clothes on and [__] you
just go out it's [__] dark as [__]
you're just doing your [__] karate
man what yeah and then you go back and
you're just like oh you take a quick
shower you go to sleep right and then
you go wiggle wiggle is [__] six and
then they're like you go [__] eat
breakfast after breakfast we're gonna do
this so then like there's no time feels
a ninja class like basically so first
for like a week straight right you just
just randomly being woken up you're just
three times a day working out each
workout is [__] intense like one we
would be horse stance for 90 minutes but
the whole time you're like dude
what yeah and then so um after after
that you're just your body's just so
exhausted what is a horse dance
yeah yeah and then the whole video yeah
yeah
for 90 minutes
90 minutes yeah yeah
I'm [__] shaking right now
[Laughter]
it's always hurricane
and the people are shaking and [__] like
oh right okay
why is that so good dude because I used
to play all the time dude
I like the little bounce
yeah so we're throwing a thousand
hadokins really and just all this energy
is going out by the time I get back dude
it feels like I have a new body it's a
weird feeling and then at that point I
don't even think about having a
cigarette or anything like that and then
so from that point on cold turkey it was
the best thing that worked for me but I
think the what you got to do is you got
to get out of your element so like
change your whole my habit yeah yeah
yeah yeah today's video is brought to
you by Warby Parker look at my
sunglasses Warby Parker offers you
everything that you need for happier
eyeballs eyeglasses sunglasses contact
lenses and even eye exams and you can
shop online or in stores if you want a
touchy feely right in front of you
feeling that glasses start at nine to
five dollars including prescription
lenses look at what I got try Warby
Parker's free home try on program order
five pairs of glasses to try at home for
free there's no obligation to buy ships
free and includes a prepaid return
shipping label if you prefer shopping in
stores Warby Parker has over a hundred
and ninety locations throughout the US
and if you're in Vegas like me you've
seen them there there's a lot there's
actually a lot so what I like about the
whole Warby Parker trial home program is
you know how sometimes you go buy
something you're like why did I buy this
you felt a certain way yeah or something
that you're stuck between two things and
you want to test drive things so I like
that it comes home into your in a box
and you're like okay quite the comfort
of my own home sometimes I want to get
something that nails like three looks I
want something that works at the beach
and casual and maybe a little bit
dressed up so you can test drive and you
can wear different outfits with it and
go you know what these are the ones that
I like and when I'm at the store I put
it on and I'm all like I'm not wearing
the right outfit but I like this does it
really make like does it work my other
clothes and then it's like you can
really you know try try that out at home
and then and you can see if it works
with your outfit try five pairs of
glasses at home for free at
warbyparker.com off the Record so you
put yourself in these intense situations
where you it's like do or die for you
that's what it sounds like you like to
like I had to because it was 25 years I
feel like you got it
25 years of smoke that sounds like my
dad like same thing kind of happened
with my dad because he tried he tried
quitting like
like his whole [__] life but then he
had a stroke
and then that'll probably do it for
somebody and then he was like you should
you should uh start doing some karate no
but then he's just good but that was
like the wake-up call that [__]
changed my goddamn life you know damn oh
should he cold quit after the stroke
yeah like as he was lighting a cigarette
he had a [__] stroke in a car
anything you like [__] I think the
heart or something is the more stressful
you should make the quit because like
like for you you just quit right so like
it's yeah how long are you doing it for
though I was doing it for like a whole
year and it was like it went from like
well I'm not gonna buy a pack that's how
I know I have a problem and I started
buying packs and then I started like
really smoking a pack a day and I was
like oh [__] this is getting intense so
then I just
one day I remember I was just grossed
out and I was just like oh that's
[__] gross 25 years is a [__] long
yeah 25 years is pretty intense easy if
it's or like if you could do it cold
turkey then I don't think you have to go
so hardcore so it depends on the person
yeah so like if someone is smoking like
half a pack a day they can't let it go
uh I think they have to do something
really crazy to let it go I like what
you're saying I'm I'm the same way I
have to put myself through physical like
um like
trauma and for real I really do for me
to change something to be like oh you
know I don't want to eat this like when
I really want to stop eating fast food
like I'll do so much exercise that like
I don't even I get grossed out just
thinking of faster because I know the
next day is going to be tougher for me
more like sluggish it's gonna hurt like
so I'd rather just not do it because
it's not gonna be worth it you know
cucumber and a chicken breast yeah two
different I don't want a milkshake she's
gonna slow me down I will say that I do
know a few a few homies that were
definitely always smoking addicted to it
smoking for a long time and then they
actually did start like vaping and then
after vaping they would quit cigarettes
and then after vaping they'll quit
vaping I started vaping in the casinos
and wherever because you know back in
the day they didn't have a rule right
yeah I'd be like I would be like Oh I'm
gonna quit smoking so I'm vaping all day
long indoors and when I go outdoors I
pull out my cigarettes you know what I
hate about cigarette people though
cigarette Community y'all need to start
buying mints
every [__] that smokes act like
they're like hey yo
[Laughter]
I just have a barber who would uh cut my
hair after like as he's cutting my hair
I could smell like he would smoke like a
blunt and then a cigarette oh that blunt
[__] and then when he would and his
mouth would be dry as [__] while he's
cutting my hair yeah and his breath
literally smelled like he ate a [__]
sandwich
I hate those [__] [__] bro so I'm
like like I'm not going to see an adult
I'm not gonna say anything yeah and he's
just like talking to me and I'm like oh
yeah that was a double standard I had so
I smoked in high school too yeah but I
did not like chicks that smoked yeah
because their cigarettes won't be all up
in their hair yeah they smelled like
[__] Bath and Body Works with
cigarettes
I remember that there's this hot girl
except me though because I smoke right
yeah so whoa whoa I didn't get it really
so you didn't like the fact that she
smoked it just didn't smell like
attractive to me
that cigarette at the time smells like a
man yeah yeah it does I was I was saying
this hot girl one time and she's just a
smoker which I was like whatever she's
got nice ass like this whatever I'll
pass by the smoking but then her breath
would just reek sometimes and I'm like
God damn it it's like yeah it's tough
hey do you ever one time I woke up in
the morning and I was like I was hey you
know we should do we should brush our
teeth and go out but I kept emphasizing
hey girl so we should go over here like
you know Downtown L.A or eat something
but then we brush our teeth
and we make sure we our teeth are
brushed before we go anyway besides this
and she was like where should I say I
have to brush my teeth I'm like well
yeah I mean did I say that like more
than once I'm sorry
I'm gonna brush our teeth
non-smoker when you kiss a smoker it's
crazy yeah like it you really tasted it
whoa I remember being a smoker dating a
smoker and it wouldn't kiss it just
tastes like sick like the the after
nicotine tastes foot it's like that
bitter taste kissing a Goodwill
that's hilarious
shot because you know how like you like
that when you when you have vintage
clothes if they were a smoker it's a
total different smell until you describe
that very [__] one I know exactly
what you're talking about it's smelling
like a Salvation Army dude
all the time smoking smell is acceptable
to me and that's like nostalgic for me
is a casino or a car
why are you Whispering it yeah someone
attempt them to move
I'm like no you guys are better than
this this is new hey the Red Rock's been
smelling like cigarettes though it does
but the the old one I wanted they got
rid of the smell and put cigarettes back
in there yeah artificial yeah you can't
go into banions [__] Golden Nugget
you can't go in there and be and smell
like clean air it has to be cigarette
with pumped up like cheap perfume yeah I
don't mind smelling it in like hotel
lobbies and casinos and stuff I don't
really mind something classy about it
dude yeah it's just it's just it's
nostalgic too yeah I I do think smoking
like visually is like pretty fun
I think it's cool I still think we're
helping the person who's asking the
question about quitting but especially
when you're old and you're like in a
[__] you have an oxygen tank and you
have a cigarette and you're at a [__]
what do you call it like those [__]
slot machines and then there's like five
old ladies that's right about to die but
they're just all smoking oh you know I
think it is though too when you see a
smoker like I'm envious of them being
able to enjoy something so casually and
publish that I feel like I want that but
do you want that little smokers feel
like like junkies in a corner yeah it
doesn't feel the same really
like there was smoking sections yeah so
like you're at the restaurant they're on
that side or even in the airplane
there's a smoking said ashtrays in the
armrest yeah those planes are from like
the 80s though and all the smokers
looked so like like they're having a
blast yeah you know they're reading a
newspaper they're smoking a cigarette
it's movies really that's what I was
trying to say when I worked at the
restaurant like they would take a
cigarette break and everybody in the
kitchen everybody in the weights that
would all go out and it was like a
community of like a hang like it was a
cigarette ago
and I was like that guy that I was just
like oh let me get one of them [__]
in that time where everyone would just
smoke cigarettes I would smoke and not
give a [__] yeah you know what I mean
just like being okay with it but I think
nowadays because it is like that where
it's like yeah you're like a junkie
going yeah you even go to the airport
you know what I mean you're in the
airport and then there's those little
ass smoking glass rooms and stuff that
everyone goes into sometimes you like
you want to go in there like hit a vape
or something like that but you're like
[__] [__] on that I'm gonna smell like
cigarettes also that nowadays you know
like slowly they were removing the
imagery of smoking as advertisement from
media and movies through the years right
so now we're only left with what it
really looks like and a lot of the time
it's not that they're closing to uh ban
the sale of cigarettes in California for
anyone that's born
um beef uh after 2007. so if you're out
yeah they're proposing all tobacco
from where we kind of talked about but
it's kind of a good idea I remember in
Mexico when uh you buy cigarettes like
they show a picture of the most
raunchiest [__] like thing that
happens
a baby has like something or like you
know these are causes like brown lungs
from smoking it has a [__] image on
the pack as you're buying it and it's
like and people just Mexico just rip it
and then they just put the little packet
I'm just like that is the gnarliest
[__] thing though yeah to show you
what could happen and you just ignore it
and just like so okay when you go walk
through Disneyland there used to be like
a really big like a smoking section yeah
yeah only and then now it's getting
smaller and smaller to the point where I
don't even know where they are anymore I
should make me feel like [__] they want
them out of view now yeah get out of
here [__] smokers yeah yeah okay
before uh we end this video Alan Carr's
easy way to quit smoking check that out
if you want to learn how to quit that
helped me out
um other there's a video on YouTube too
that shows you like from months to years
of how your body heals after quitting
smoking like within 24 hours this is
what happens to your body 48 hours all
that and then pretty much the cool thing
about quitting smoking though is like
within like five to ten years you have a
whole new body and whole new lungs and
all that stuff it regenerates yeah you
basically reduce the risk of like let's
say you're a smoker now right you said
and then you're like 30 percent more
likely to have a heart attack or like
there's these crazy statistics as soon
as you quit the the the that percentage
drops like crazy so it's not like you're
done and you're gonna just be you know
[__] forever and that's the cool part
because for me I feel like there's hella
effects because I've been smoking for
most of my life right and then one thing
that I have noticed when I quit was
waking up was so hard as a smoker and I
think it has something to do with
restricting your blood flow or recovery
something's weird yeah or it took me
forever to like I'd be groggy or
whatever but then like um after a year
quitting I I just wake up and then my
body just feels normal like I don't feel
like always nah my IBS went away
um I was [__] diarrhea every day yeah
I had stomach acid issues I had so many
different things yeah when I was talking
that's one of the only reasons why I
didn't like it because I was having a
lot of like screws up your gut health
yeah and then when it's and it just all
disappears yeah
foreign